there's another rule change big cat i
want to get your thoughts on before we
take a break and that is and we're told
that there is growing support for the
alternative to the onside kick a fourth
and 15 play that could be used twice per
game
at the choice of the
the team that is otherwise kicking off
you get a fourth and 15 player from your
own 25 if you convert a first down you
keep possession if you don't convert the
opposing team takes over you can't do
anything fancy or tricky like punt and
something that mds noticed in the
formulation of this rule
the
the idea that if you score late
and you're ahead and there's just a
couple seconds left on the clock you do
the fourth and 15. you don't kick the
ball and you just run around until the
clock runs out and you run out of bounds
now look they may close that loophole by
saying you can only use that play if
you're trailing
but fourth and 15 an alternative to the
onside kick that a team may be able to
use and the support is growing for that
look they're trying to take the kickoff
play out of the game but they recognize
it's so hard to convert an onside kick
now they need another way for teams to
keep possession when they're trying to
keep a game interesting i've been
pushing this for a while now i'm i'm a
proponent just getting rid of the
kickoff all together and making a fourth
and 15 play and you can punt or you can
go for it you can do a fake punt you can
act like you're going for it and you can
do a pooch punt like the old ben
rothersburg or randall cunningham punt i
mean you can do all sorts of stuff out
of that fourth and 15. i wish they would
just make it fourth and 15. but this is
a step in that direction your thoughts
on a potential fourth and 15 alternative
to the onside kick
i love it i love it this adds more
excitement to the game the fact that if
you have an offense that you you know
you're confident in your offense you
feel like they can convert something
like that there'll be more memorable
moments because we do have so many times
where uh an onside kick with the new
rules of onside kicks they just don't
happen and the game kind of ends so i'm
all in favor of this i think it adds the
excitement it adds the intrigue i i
think the only other thing that i would
add if we were talking about rules mike
is and i i know people would probably
disagree with this i think the the rules
in college football where you can start
where you stop the clock until the ball
is snapped after a first down at the end
of games adds more excitement adds i
mean the games go really long but adds
more excitement adds the ability to come
back that's what you're looking for
those are the games we remember when
teams have furious comebacks and they'll
convert a fourth and 15 instead of an
onside kick and then the off they go
that's that's what gets the juices
flowing so i think this is a great rule
i'm all in for it uh get it done get
this and sky judge 10 000 done today
nothing in the current proposal requires
the team to be trailing so a team could
and that would be a bill belichick move
take the lead late and do the fourth and
15 play and just kill the clock on that
fourth and 15th play and never give the
ball to the other team also you touched
on a very important point it was six
years ago that the nfl hosted the super
bowl in new york and i vividly recall
seeing roger goodell being interviewed
by someone i think from cnbc
and he was asked who do you root for and
his response was whoever is trailing he
wants teams to have a chance to come
back he wants the games to be exciting
they need to have a viable onside kick
alternative if the new rules of the
kickoff don't allow the onside kick to
happen in a productive way now the the
next step and to the extent the nfl is
maybe cherry-picking some of these ideas
from failed spring football leagues
let's do the xfl electric football
kickoff where you've got all those guys
frozen in place like the old electric
football figures while the ball is
kicked and as soon as the guy recovers
it air it's like turning the switch on
the machine and they all take off that
was the most compelling aspect of the
xfl it makes for a safer play because
you're not at full speed when you impact
with the person that you're blocking or
the person that is trying to get past
the block to make the tackle i'd like to
see them go that far as well maybe
that's something they'll do next year
they should hire my friend sam
schwartstein who is uh director of uh
football ops for the xfl because that
was his rule he came up with and he came
up with a bunch of different rules you
need someone like you said who's not
walling everything off and who's who's
open to innovation open to talking to
different people over to talking to
gamblers openly talking to people who've
been around football for a long time
casual fans that's the thing innovation
is only a good thing when it comes to
rule changes and how we can evolve the
game
and uh you know
your buddy may not be available next
year if that's the case because uh and
and i don't want to get far afield here
but there's a chance the xfl will be
back next year there's a chance vince
mcmahon is going to buy his own football
league out of bankruptcy and bring it
back so we'll see what happens all right
we got a patrick mahomes tweet on this
and he's not he he's what is he is he
what's he doing what does that mean i
don't understand emojis get it easily
oh okay i got it yeah like yeah like
that's nothing like that's easy it's not
like a guy
yeah
yeah all right well good ma i i'm good i
i i want to now look i don't want to see
a team that's dominating a game just
keep possession and play keep away but i
i like the idea that a team that's
trailing has a way to keep possession
and you're right the better your offense
is the better your quarterback is and i
know sims isn't here today obviously but
his argument against it is your defense
your defense has just given up a score
your defense may be tired and you're
going to make them go back out there and
play another play and stop a fourth and
15 and then stay on the field after that
if they if they can't stop the fourth
and 15 but uh i got no problem with it i
would like a device that lets
that lets the team that's trailing get
back into the game and the onside kick
is no longer effective because of the
new formation big cat yeah yeah and and
i do what you just said like the the
element of it could be like a one-on-one
basketball game where where you know you
play winners if you score you get to
keep the ball
i think that the fact that it starts 25
yard line make it take it
the 25 yard line will probably deter
that although there will be a coach i'm
sure when they crunch the numbers if
their offense is really that good where
they say why would we kick the ball off
when we can convert a fourth and 15 75
of the time or whatever it may be but
eventually there will be an offense like
that and guess what it will probably be
patrick from home's offense
i'll be doing it in madden every single
day you can bank on that
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports